[Música]
en nuestra sección de salud en directo
América con Marina sardiña el día de hoy
el tema es el tabaquismo un nuevo
estudio Calcula que las personas que
dejan de fumar antes de cumplir 45 años
tienen un riesgo de mortalidad similar a
las personas que nunca fumaron y con
este preámbulo pues la bienvenida para
ustedes Marina gracias Y tenemos también
un invitado especial en el estudio
Buenos días Ángela y buenos días doctor
Franco nos hace mucha ilusión tenerlo
por fin aquí en nuestro plató el doctor
es nuestro asesor de salud que nos viene
acompañando en los últimos años y que
hoy nos está acompañando desde Bogotá y
no desde Países Bajos como la hace
frecuentemente Muchas gracias por estar
Y si Ángela como decías el tabaquismo es
una de las principales causas de muertes
prevenibles en el mundo se calcula Según
la OMS que 8.2 millones de personas
mueren cada año por consumir tabaco
también entonces doctor Vamos a hablar
contigo de este tema porque por este
nuevo informe que dice que dejar de
fumar antes de los 45 años reduciría el
riesgo de morir a los niveles de un no
fumador cómo funciona esta relación
entre el número de años que estamos
consumiendo tabaco y el dejar de fumar
fumar es como tener una cuenta bancaria
de cosas malas entonces cada cigarrillo
que tú vas fumando cada año que vas
fumando vas aumentando vas consignando
en esa cuenta de cosas malas entonces
dejar de agregar esa cuenta y dejar
durante un tiempo de estar contribuyendo
a fumar y
afectar tu salud va reduciendo los
efectos del etéreos que tiene El
cigarrillo en tu organismo Entonces el
mensaje Generalmente para todos es
primero no fumen es uno de los flagelos
más grandes que afecta la salud en el
mundo y segundo paran de fumar lo antes
posible siempre van a tener beneficios
Nunca es tarde Pero entre más temprano
mejor y precisamente los fumadores se
revierten estos efectos del tabaquismo
en nuestro organismo o realmente quedan
secuelas
dependiendo del número de años que
estamos fumando si algunos daños que son
irreversibles tenemos que entender que
El cigarrillo como tal es una sustancia
tóxica tiene más de algunos dicen de
5000 7000 toxinas de cosas que tienen
bastante daño no solamente en nuestra
respiración en las células de los
pulmones del corazón también en el
sistema nervioso entonces lo que se ve
es por ejemplo
después de 24 horas de dejar de fumar ya
se empieza a ver una reducción en la
presión arterial después de una semana
más o menos empieza a ver mejoría en las
conexiones de las de los nervios que nos
permiten oler el olfato y el gusto
Entonces ya se empieza a ver una mejoría
y también se empiezan a ver una
reducción de un de de monóxido de
carbono que afecta el consumo o el
intercambio de gases en nuestro
organismo entonces la disponibilidad de
oxígeno para nuestros tejidos que es
esencial como alimento empieza a empiezo
a aumentar entonces empiezan a ver ya
desde los de los primeros días de las
primeras semanas una reducción en esos
efectos una cosa importante es la
primera semana dejar de fumar para los
fumadores cuando empiezan a dejar de
fumar lograr Esa primera semana de no
fumarse un cigarrillo generalmente se
asocia con un 9% más de riesgo o de
probabilidad de poder dejar de fumar
doctor Qué otros factores influyen Como
por ejemplo el género o la etnia como se
ven involucrados Sí hemos visto en
diferentes ubicaciones geográficas los
problemas pueden afectar más a ciertas
minorías étnicas o a la mujer por
ejemplo en Europa ahora mismo en la
Unión Europea el objetivo es tratar de
reducir el tabaquismo a la mujer en la
epidemia de tabaquismo como le llamamos
la epidemia o la pandemia de tabaquismo
realmente vemos cómo empiezan los
hombres a aumentar a fumar y
gradualmente empiezan las mujeres
también aumentar ahora mismo en el Reino
Unido entre la población joven hay más
fumadoras que fumadores entonces y las
compañías también también han
desarrollado unos sistemas en que se
venden cigarrillos que son estéticamente
más bonitos entonces son delgados o
largos o tienen Sabores o les llaman
Lights o les ponen un filtro más grande
y realmente tienen el mismo riesgo que
cualquier otro cigarrillo entonces uno
de los objetivos en la Unión Europea es
quitar esa imagen que tiene ese
cigarrillo estético que trata de de
afectar a la mujer y tratar de
simplemente impedir que continúe el
tabaquismo uno de esos pocos segmentos
que no habían dedicado a las mujeres
como objetivo de publicidad
completamente también doctor la nicotina
No ya hemos hablado que es una sustancia
altamente Adictiva
cuéntanos Un poco cómo actúan nuestro
organismo y los efectos esta vez a largo
plazo de dejar esta sustancia si es una
sustancia que no es la única porque
todavía se está tratando de entender
Cuáles son todas esas toxinas de las 5.7
mil toxinas que se han descrito en un
cigarrillo Imagínate la bomba toxinas
que es un solo cigarrillo estos efectos
a largo plazo entonces El cigarrillo va
afectando tu sistema cardiovascular hace
que las arterias se hagan más duras que
respondan menos a los desafíos que tú
vives en tu propio metabolismo afecta la
respiración afecta la fertilidad cuando
hablábamos de la mujer y también como
sabemos es una de las principales causas
de hecho dentro de las 10 principales
causas de muerte en el mundo 9 tienen
algún tipo de relación con el cigarrillo
lo que vemos Es que después de dejar de
fumar a partir de los 5 años empieza a
reducir el riesgo de enfermedades del
corazón A partir de los 10 años el
riesgo de tener cáncer a partir de los
15 años el riesgo de cáncer de pulmón
que es uno de los cánceres que afecta
más el consumo del cigarrillo empieza a
reducirse a hacerse Casi casi similar a
las personas que no han fumado
creo que es importante ser claro lo que
veíamos en este estudio que hablaban que
se reducía el riesgo y que realmente
después antes de los se dejaba de fumar
antes de los 45 que las cosas son como
como si fueran normales la realidad es
otra los daños que dejan cigarrillo
algunos daños son permanentes si se
mitigan con el tiempo pero los daños que
quedan aún pueden ser permanentes uno de
los grandes temas de discusión de los
últimos años se ha enfocado en los
cigarrillos electrónicos que son más
bonitos que al principio se pensaba
bueno El cigarrillo electrónico pues
mejor que un cigarrillo convencional
pero no son inofensivos pueden exponer a
quienes usan estas sustancias a efectos
de salud adversos muchos fumadores de
cigarrillos se cambian al vapeador
creyendo esto que son menos nocivos para
la salud pero esa no es la realidad Cuál
es entonces doctor la realidad es que en
primer lugar son tan adictivos o casi
tan adictivos como El cigarrillo normal
también contienen nicotina y otros 3.000
4.000 toxinas que todavía se están
tratando entender qué es lo que tienen
estos cigarrillos y En tercer lugar
están buscando tratar de afectar a la
población joven que les parece que es
como más cool o que está más bien como
más en moda entonces utilizan estos
cigarrillos también porque el olor no
afecta tanto pero lo que hemos visto
cada vez más y más y más evidencia es
que son muy dañinos no son beneficiosos
para la salud y ese esa historia de que
nos podía ayudar a que a dejar que las
personas dejen de fumar realmente es
mentira lo que se ha visto es que los
fumadores que empiezan a cambiar los
cigarrillos convencionales por estos
cigarrillos electrónicos en muchos
lugares no solamente se hacen adictos a
los cigarrillos electrónicos sino que
continúan también fumando de vez en
cuando entonces como que se multiplican
los efectos dañinos el mensaje es por
favor no utilicen los cigarrillos ni los
convencionales ni los electrónicos ni
piensan que este va a ser una solución o
un atajo sencillo para dejar de fumar es
una gran mentira realmente tienen un
riesgo para la salud y no pueden
utilizar por supuesto y precisamente de
este riesgo el tabaquismo lo estamos
hablando o sea comúnmente se habla como
si fuera un vicio un hábito y no como un
problema de salud ni como una adicción
Porque desde el sistema sanitario es de
los gobiernos no lo tratan como tal como
una como un problema de salud pública y
ponen medidas médicas y también por
ejemplo psicológicas para ayudar a la
gente a dejar de fumar cierto es un
problema demasiado complejo no solamente
de salud sino también económico los
millones que tú te gastas durante la
vida comprando cigarrillos la cantidad
de tiempo que te gastas saliendo a
comprar un cigarrillo fumándote El
cigarrillo dejando de hacer las
actividades que podrías hacer los años
de vida que tú te cortas porque más o
menos una persona que fumas reduce la
expectativa de villanos seis siete años
menos que los demás entonces Y encima de
todo tenemos las empresas que pues
venden estos productos que quieren tener
clientes y que están utilizando también
el los cigarrillos electrónicos como un
un vistazo dentro del mercado para poder
seguir vendiendo estos estos productos
que realmente tienen muchísimo daño en
la salud esto además es un problema
también político porque muchas de estas
empresas pagan unos aranceles muy altos
o los gobiernos tienen grandes
influencias en las políticas de salud en
las políticas económicas y para muchos
gobiernos les es muy difícil cortar esa
dependencia económica que se ha ido
creando con estas empresas entonces la
verdad es un fenómeno sociocultural muy
complicado no solamente de salud pública
pero yo creo que se debería revertir a
mirar al fumador como un adicto que
requiere tratamiento que requiere apoyo
que requiere una ayuda psicológica que
requiere tratamiento realmente
seguimiento y que necesita un apoyo del
sistema de salud claro por supuesto y
precisamente la lucha con las
multinacionales del tabaco es lo que y
contra la publicidad no que llega es lo
que tenemos que también que centrar la
atención porque qué podemos hacer qué
podemos hacer desde la sociedad hasta
los medios de comunicación pero también
desde los gobiernos y desde los
ministerios de sanidad qué campañas se
pueden implementar para para
contrarrestar este poder tan fuerte que
tienen las multinacionales si es un
movimiento que tiene que ser
estructuralmente de la sociedad no
solamente de los políticos y las
políticas que se van a implementar de
salud sino también las personas que son
youtubers o que tienen influencia pueden
jugar un papel muy importante porque la
comunicación ahora mismo con los jóvenes
que son los que los que más se afectan
por el cigarrillo para empezar a fumar y
que no pueden dejar de fumar
realmente no se comunican a través de
los canales que nosotros normalmente nos
comunicamos Hace unos días o 20 años
entonces es muy importante crear toda
una estrategia Social para poder tratar
este flagelo eliminarlo y ayudar a la
gente a vivir mejor doctor nosotros
comenzamos en contacto con ustedes ella
algo más de dos años por la noticia que
cambió el mundo y que seguirá registrada
en la historia es la pandemia del covid
19 Ahora nos podemos no solo encontrar
físicamente sino que con la libertad de
abrazarnos y de no ponernos un tapabocas
para poder sostener esta charla que
tenemos aquí en el estudio
quisiera por favor después de haber
vivido todo este proceso con frases 24 y
con otros medios de comunicación como
evalúa usted de esta pandemia que está
llegando a su fin y que ahora nos
permite enfocarnos en otros temas de
salud pública tan importantes como este
que hemos hablado del cigarrillo en
primer lugar Pues si llevamos varios
años trabajando juntos me ha encantado
trabajar con ustedes para mí me parece
esencial como científico como médico
como especialista en salud pública en
epidemiología Me parece asociar que la
comunicación llegue a las personas que
la necesitan y ustedes juegan un papel
muy importante en llegar a esas personas
que no están llegando al consultorio y
que podemos llevarle un mensaje de
optimismo un mensaje de poder mejorar la
vida pero en palabras Un poco más
sencillas para que las personas
realmente puedan tomar cierta acción la
pandemia no se ha acabado realmente
estamos aún en pandemia no sabemos cómo
se va a comportar este virus estamos en
una competencia
una maratón de especies evolutiva que
estamos con compitiendo con este virus
que se adapta cada vez mejor y ojalá que
las vacunas que han sido uno de los
logros más grandes de la humanidad en la
historia yo creo nos pueden ayudar a
poder mitigar el efecto de las pandemias
la forma en que estamos viviendo puede
generar más pandemias a futuro pero yo
creo que ahora mismo lo que tenemos que
ver es después de estos dos años tan
difíciles que vivimos que aprendimos que
nos queda Cómo podemos cambiar y cómo
como sociedad y como estructura en
términos de salud cómo nos podemos
preparar mejor para los desafíos que
vienen a futuro